YouTube faces growing questions about
how it police's content after failing to
remove a graphic video from its site
social media star Logan Paul apologized
this week for posting a video to YouTube
showing the body of an apparent suicide
victim it stayed on the site for at
least 24 hours and was reportedly viewed
more than six million times
Paul deleted the video after rising
backlash and announced last night that
he was taking a break YouTube said in a
statement if a video is graphic it can
only remain on the site when supported
by appropriate educational or
documentary information the company CEO
promised last month to increase its
content moderator team to more than ten
thousand people this followed reports of
disturbing videos targeted at kids CBS
News contributor Nicholas Thompson is
editor-in-chief of Wired and Nick good
morning morning jack so more than ten
thousand people yet this video remained
up on the site for the least 24 hours
and had six million people view it so
what we know happen is the video goes up
on the site a bunch of people report it
cuz there's a button on YouTube when you
see something offensive and anybody who
saw this would have should have thought
this is offensive and crazy it went to
YouTube a human then approved it and
said this is OK but then because there
were so many reports are because of some
other system it eventually went to
somebody else and then YouTube was like
oh we should take that down at that
point was right about when Logan Paul
took the video down himself we talked
about the people who were set to monitor
this right 10,000 folks monitoring
videos but there are over 400 hours of
video shared on YouTube every minute
yeah that is daunting right so there's
this huge tension in all of these
Silicon Valley companies like whether
they're a platform which just allows
people to publish whatever they want and
there's no system to control it or
whether they're a publisher and they're
more like CBS or there are lots of
people and their ethical standards and
guidelines and clearly there's somewhere
in between and so there's just big
debate in Silicon Valley about where in
the spectrum are you do you allow people
to publish whatever you want and have
limited looks at it or do you have a
whole bunch of standards and a whole
bunch of people reviewing it and you can
see them moving across the spectrum
YouTube's problem is they're probably a
little too close to the platform side
and there's a huge advantage to that
right if you let people publish whatever
they want as quickly as possible and
it's pretty hard to have it taken down
you get a lot more content it's easier
for local Paul and he's less likely to
go to Facebook but how does that score
with the YouTube told us quote the
company prohibits violent or gory
content posted in a shocking sensational
or disrespectful manner as you say this
made it to a top trending list yeah how
does the company enforce that the policy
is even though is that it does have
right so there is a policy the policy is
a good policy they should probably have
a stronger policy the problem here is
that this just got through right I think
it's probably a combination if there is
a little bit of video he does say some
things to try to cover himself though
he's mocking a suicide victim while
wearing a hat with eyeballs right I mean
it's not something that should have been
knocked down and then secondly it
happened on Year's Eve I think probably
a lot of YouTube people were part of a
larger discussion about these extremely
powerful and profitable online media
agencies if you want to call them that
or they they house a lot of contact what
content whether they're gonna police or
monitor that content that is exactly
what this is so what we called foreign
wire to say this is a moment of
reckoning for YouTube and YouTube should
say okay we've had a guy who's popular
among kids
mocking suicide right you don't get
worse than that and it got through for
24 hours so we need to develop a system
YouTube needs to develop a system it
needs to have clearer rules it probably
needs to have more moderators maybe it
needs to have more transparency about
how the moderation works it needs to put
all these things together and it needs
to do it fairly quickly it's but it's
not just YouTube it's a lot of these a
lot of these sites note you actually
have to pay people then to look at this
stuff
right and watch this Duncan make these
editorial decisions and say this should
not be on well mountain of data we're
talking about that they have to sift
through even if they do hire more people
right it's hard but it's also more
algorithms remember right they use
algorithms to knock out pornography and
they do a very good job of that so the
algorithms need to get more
sophisticated and the algorithms are
looking at the images seamless an image
and also seeing how people react looking
at the comments seeing how people report
the scale which people report so there
is a way to do this but again here crazy
concept it might take more than
algorithms right it's actually I'm not
it takes desire on the part of the
company correct
it takes desire takes algorithms it
takes people I think YouTube it's smart
they care about this stuff and there
gonna lose money too here right there
financial incentives are aligned right
look and Paul's making a lot of money
looking Paul's can be making a lot less
money in the future than he was which
means YouTube's been making less money
in Logan Paul so it's in their interest
to fix this but it's a complicated
problem yeah which is a very good point
that they take a cut of this whatever
money he makes right he didn't make
money on this video cuz he turned off
ads but in general YouTube gets a cut of
all the ads that appear on local Paul
stuff sometimes it's like 45% Nick
Thompson thank you so much thank you